six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's see who else is on the phone today
we have 32 people holding more than than
we've ever had let's try the two one six
area code caller from two one six hello
who are you where are you calling from
what's on your mind today
hey David my name is Ken I'm from
Cleveland Ohio I and a couple I'd like
to maybe frame up premise for you to
kind of respond to and sure you can tell
me what you think um I actually was just
listening to a while either this week
your debate about the death penalty and
it really tied together well with the I
don't know if you've heard of kayfabe or
watch Pro Wrestling wisecrack on youtube
has a good um I don't know if you're
familiar with that term kayfabe I am
okay it's sort of when there's a
presentation or a entertainment where
the presenters know they're fake and the
audience know they're fake but
everyone's kind of playing along and
it's sort of went perfectly with kind of
your discussion about the death penalty
where you had people who it seems like
had never even been in a courtroom
talking about these very high level and
complicated issues and I see this all
the time I actually heard Glenn Lowry
with Larry Kotlikoff on The Economist
I'm not sure if you're familiar with
them but they were talking about
affirmative action and Larry talks about
you know how just a very basic and
meanwhile claims like oh what if we just
get rid of it and Glenn's point is very
well taken in with all the different
intricacies of it and I guess what I
think is these issues that we're talking
about when you talk about $15 minimum
wage affirmative action universal health
care things like this they're just too
complicated and we have this party and
the Democrats that you know as another
college that almost feels so divided but
there's just these answers these
tailored answers that are barely policy
prescriptions that are it just doesn't
feel like I can't trouble just worrying
about the Democrats in voting for a
Democrat because I don't see real
answers because the right is just so
just
functional but I have a problem with the
Democrats because we're not able to make
these ballistic policies because they're
worried about getting enough votes to
compete with Republicans I don't know if
that makes any sense it's a shot out of
a cannon today and I love it so here's
the thing I get what you're saying that
there particularly when you're in the
opposition you have to sort of try to
lay out your position or policy idea as
simply as possible in order for it to at
least appear politically viable and that
doesn't really get as nuanced
discussions of policy but I don't know
that I agree with you that the Democrats
are just wrong on a lot of these I mean
so like for example Medicare for all as
an example which is not the official
position of the Democratic Party but
there are increasingly more and more
Democrats who support that yes you can
hear sorry cannot it would it be okay if
I give you the full answer yeah okay
okay you can make the argument that in
order to actually get to the point of
implementation of Medicare for all yes
you need a lot of different systems you
need to figure out the financial side of
it you need to figure out the legal side
of it you need to figure out the
technical and implementation and
logistical side of it but just because
you have more and more Democrats saying
hold on a second we know of another
system that would work and it's Medicare
for all I don't know that that's really
something fair to criticize the
Democrats on because they're they're
sort of coming up with these one-liners
because that's that's step one in moving
the conversation okay yes that's a great
answer but where I disagree with you and
I don't know if you've looked into many
of the races is the Democrats have a
tough time with Medicare Medicare for
all the established Democrats there was
a great expose on this American Life a
couple weeks ago where they actually
detailed some primary races several
across the country where Medicare for
all Democrats were not able to secure
funding at all so the Democratic Party
were actually shunned from from
basically receiving funding and
information like that that's a different
argument the argument that so I was just
using medicare-for-all as an example but
your initial criticism was you just
weren't hearing depth and nuance and
ideas from Democrats now you're saying
you are hearing it but the Democratic
Party won't fund them which is that's a
that's a relevant conversation but a
very different one well I think it's
intertwined because you can't have the
conversations within the Democratic
Party because the special interests
within the Democratic Party are more
interested in one-liners and maybe it
isn't Medicare for all but and I do
agree with your premise that obviously
you want
okay and with that pop we we lost Ken we
may have gotten as far as we were going
to go